if x is equal to 20 so this right over
here is a 20 degree angle
and this one also is a 20 degree angle
and y is equal to 30 so this right over
here which is a different color
this right over here is having trouble
switching colors that's a 30 degree
angle in the figure above what is the
value of z right over here this is a
little bit strange at first because
it it feels like we might be able to use
triangles somehow but this whole shape
is not a triangle
but if we could construct a triangle
where we know two of the angles of the
triangle then we know we can always
figure out the third because we know the
sum of the interior angles of a triangle
add up to 180.
so
can we construct a triangle where we
know two of the angles so let's think
about it so this is we know this is 30
degrees we know this is 20 degrees can
we construct a triangle where these are
two of the angles of that triangle
well what if we
what if we extend
this side
to go all the way over here now we have
we know two of the angles of a triangle
now we should be able to figure out
this third angle right over here and
what is that third angle going to be
well 30 degrees plus this angle plus 20
degrees is going to be 180 or another
way to think about it this is going to
be 180 degrees
minus 30 minus 20 or this is going to be
180 degrees minus 50. so this is going
to be
130 degrees
now if we know that we can figure out
what this angle is going to be because
these two angles are supplementary they
are going to add up to 180 degrees when
you go all the way around you've
essentially you've gone all the way or
you go halfway around the circle or you
can you can kind of say the two rays of
the angle form a line
and so what plus 130 is 180 well 180
minus 130 is 50 degrees
so this is 50 degrees
what do we know
what do we know about this angle
right over here
well 50 plus 20
plus this is going to be 180 so or
another way of thinking about it this is
going to be 180 minus 50 minus 20. or
180 minus what is this minus 70. so this
is going to be 110 degrees
well that's 110 degrees now we're really
cutting to the chase because this
that angle that angle is supplementary
with the angle that has
measure z degrees so we know z plus 110
z plus 110 is going to be equal to 180
or subtract 110 from both sides you get
z
is equal to
70. and we're done